the principles of success
pocket adventure miniseries in 30 minutes and
eight episodes
episode 1 going on an adventure
to begin i want one thing to be
clear
what i know is nothing compared to
what i  should know I owe
my success much more to my ability to face
my ignorance case what I know there is
therefore some presumption on my part to
claim to give advice to others this
is however what I will do because
I believe  that the principles that made
me successful can help other
people reach their goal
I have now reached a point in
my life where it is more important for me
to pass on what I know of
success than to accumulate new
success use its principles as you see
fit you must learn to think
for yourself because only you could
develop your own principles
anchored in your values ​​which brings me to
my first principle which is also
the most important
you must learn  try to discern the
truth for yourself
let's go i found out very quickly that
i needed a principle
a principle is a smart way
to approach a problem that recurs in
similar situations
there are principles for everything that
raised
children cooking etc i'm going to introduce you to
some of my
most important life principles it influences
how we approach everything
i was not born with principles they
come to me from a lifetime of experience they
are above all the fruit of my mistakes
and the lessons I learned from them my
principles of life are simple but they
are not complete
I always have trouble reaching the
best decision I keep making
mistakes I am constantly discovering
new principles is reality
in the beginning i needed to break the
shackles of convention
which meant i had to
learn to think for myself unless
you are willing to hand over
control to others  your life you have to make
your decisions yourself and have the
courage to carry them out
[Music]
initially I did not know it I only
learned them during my adventure
when I consider my journey I
now see time as a river
that takes us  door to encounters with
the reality that forces us to make
decisions
we can neither prevent our
downward drift nor avoid encounters
we can only approach them in the
best
possible way in your lifetime you will have to
take millions  of decisions their
qualities will determine the quality of your life
some of the most valuable lessons
I have learned from life were the
result of mistakes that led
me to reflect and form principles
to avoid repeating
these principles  made the average kid
that ge was typical
ngo island middle class
the successful entrepreneur at least
by convention i've become they also
show  also leads to a
professional life and to
rich and deep relationships much more important
for me than these conventional successes
I am often asked what made my
success I can certify one thing to you
it is not because I am unique
my success  is the result of a
unique approach to life that I believe
everyone can adopt
it begins with the concern to
apprehend reality and to face it
in episode 2 I will explain to you what
that means your choice  the most
important thing is the path you will
take I wanted to live an extraordinary
life boredom at mediocrity scared me more
than failure as I started with no
money but need did not exceed
living and sleeping I  I could influence
my decisions according to my adventures
since I was little I rushed after
what I wanted
I sometimes fell I got up
and started again and I fell again
each time I fell I learned
I improved and  p  little by little I
fell less often by constantly starting over
I learned to love this process
including the falls
it confronting me with reality and
I learned to face
it which inspired me one of my principles
the  more
fundamental truth is the essential foundation
for achieving positive results by
truth i mean the way the
world works
i believe the laws of reality
were given to us by nature we
are not the authors but we can
use them to evolve and achieve
our goals
this awareness made me
not a realistic father
I discovered how
deeply understanding reality and accepting it
as such and not as I wanted
and working with this material is
very  rewarding
when i call myself hyper realistic
my interlocutors often believe that i
deny the power of dreams
this is absolutely not the case without
dreams life is pointless i
simply want to say that hyper r  ealism and
the best way to choose your
dreams and achieve them
dreaming ambitiously
understanding reality and showing
unfailing determination will
lead you on the path to success I
believe this formula applies to
everyone but what does it look like  a successful life
it is up to each of us to
define success according to his views whether
your ambition is to dominate the world
or to live under the coconut trees or other
things it does not matter
each of us defines his objectives
according to its values ​​and chooses the
best path to achieve them, but
a good decision stems from a
specific approach, especially when a
problem, an error or a weakness
blocks our way to succeed involves
understanding each of the facets of our
reality, in particular
harsh realities that we would love was initially unaware of
the contemplation of these
harsh realities made me suffer but
I learned that this  your pain was
only psychological and that looking at
things in a different light changed everything
I came to see problems
as puzzles whose solution
carrying in itself it rewarded it
helped me to solve my problem and
did not bring  principles for dealing with
similar problems in the future
i learned to see pain as a
sign that a real opportunity to learn
was within my reach
which made me realize that
pain plus reflection equals progress
meditation m  was precious to
learn to see things so
I found that if I imposed calm on myself if I
accepted reality and if
I faced it I would enjoy it and
that the pain would weigh down in turn
each of us is endowed with a
unique ability to think logically about ourselves
and our situation to guide our
personal evolution
for this you just have to follow a
simple five-step process
in episode 3 we will see
how to use it we have seen the  important  this
of careful reflection
after the experience of pain when
I gave myself up I was often able to
discover principles which later
prevented me from repeating the same mistakes
and I found that success could
be summed up in five  stages the first
is to know your goals and try
to achieve them
what suits you best depends on
your nature so you have to get to
know yourself and determine what you
want to do with your life
in the second stage you have
to face the  problems that
prevent you from reaching your goals
these are usually painful if
you do it wrong they can
destroy you but to evolve you
must know them without indulgence
the third step is that of the
diagnosis of identification of the root causes
do not skip  conclusions
pause and reflect to discern
the true symptoms of the disease
the fourth step is to develop
a plan to remedy  er to the
problem this is when you determine
the way forward to overcome them
the fifth stage is
the execution stage where you make
the effort required to achieve your
goals success in life consists
mainly of repeating over and over  its
five
steps this is how you will grow and this
process is the same everywhere
this is a law of nature think of
a product an organization or a
person you know and you will
find that this is also the case
for them evolved is simply
adapt or
die conceptually they don't
differ much from these five steps by
continuing this often
painful process you naturally go to
ever higher degrees of success
i have found that  despite my
progress the difficulty never diminished
because the more I developed my
abilities the
more the challenges were difficult to
overcome we all have
strengths and weak points
few are those who pass through these
five stages without
fail denying this reality may
force
you to try harder than necessary and the higher you rise the
harder perhaps the
fall life is not free from disaster
they can cause us  break up or help
us grow it
all depends on what we do with
it something like this happened to me in
1982 in episode 4 i'll tell
you what happened and how i reacted
we move on to  whether we
encounter a setback whether we
overcome it and keep moving forward or
not depends on our willingness to look
the checks in the face objectively and
make the right decisions to
continue the
ascent disaster happened to me in 1982
when I  bet everything on an
economic crisis that never happened
the period from 1979 to 1982 was marked
by severe turbulence for
the world economy the markets and
me and i was convinced that the
american economy and the eco  world economy with
it was going straight to disaster
this opinion was far from being the
majority but I wanted to make a
move
so I very publicly took a big
risk and I was
really really wrong with a
delay in the markets or  started a
frantic ascent that lasted 18 years and
the american economy experienced
the most brilliant period of expansion in its
history
this experience was a crushing blow for me
i took a jacket so
that my company bridgwater s  ended up
with only one employee I was so
broke I had to borrow $4000 from
my father but the worst part was having to
fire people
I cared about
[Music]
I wondered if I should give up
on my dream  of an entrepreneur and choosing
security with a job requiring the wearing
of a tie and daily trips to and from the
office, knowing
that for me less risk was
synonymous with a life on the cheap, it was
doubly humiliating  iant to have erred so
grossly here publicly to this
day I still stand amazed at
my arrogance my self-confidence and
error and am ashamed of it
[Music]
though having been more often right than
thor I m  was indulged in
reckless bets that negated
everyone else's profit I spent a lot
of time thinking about the
risk-reward ratios and how
to manage it but couldn't understand
how to get the desired results
without taking a risk  unacceptable
everyone has this experience
at some point you will too
you will lose something or someone
without whom life seems
impossible
you will suffer from a terrible
illness or disability or your
career will explode before your eyes you
feel like your life is
destroyed and you have
no future
but that feeling will pass
the future is never closed there is
a better way you probably see it
not yet to discern it
nothing beats a reflection that you have
to reconcile with your rice
in the fifth episode we will see
how this realization
made me wonder how
reality works and how to deal with
it sometimes events are
difficult to understand life
often seems arduous and confusing it throws us
in the face more than we can
bear the pain that i have proven my
strength and to reflect hard on my
situation
it has also led me to reflect on the
nature our  touchstone in terms
of truth I thought intensely about
reality which helped me to take some
distance from myself and my
situation I understood that the laws a
universal force was born and had
begun their  expansion with the big bang
and that they interact in a
perpetual Brownian movement in which
parts and elements aggregate to
form dfmr machine which disintegrates
to form new ce
phenomenon repeats itself perpetually I
discovered that everything was machine the
structure and evolution of galaxies
the formation of our own
solar system geography ya earth ecosystems
our economies and market and
each of us each of us is a
machine made up of machines
our circulatory system our
nervous system which produces our thoughts our
dreams our emotions and all that makes up
our individual personality
these machines evolved together over
time to produce the realities of
everyday life and I understood that I was
only a thinking reed  deciding in a
nanosecond what I should do
this point of view may seem very
philosophical but it seemed very
practical to me because it showed me that
there was a better way for me
to face my reality I thus
noticed that  almost everything repeats itself over and over
again in slightly
different ways sometimes in short cycles easy to
recognize so that we know the
manage like the 24 hours of the
day others are so long that they have not
produced any effect in our lifetime and
when they do
we are surprised like the storm
without tonal others whose we
cannot dodge the  novelty although
they are known to us birth of a
first
child most people wrongly look at these
situations as unique and approach them
without putting them into perspective as they
should or using principles
to help them
I understand that  instead of
considering them as isolated cases
I could classify them as such a
situation and approach them
as a biologist would approach an
animal by first identifying the
species before using principle to
handle the question as appropriate
because I  noticed that the evolution
of these events were very
similar from one time to another I
distinguished more clearly
the cause and effect relationship governing their
behavior and I was thus able to equip myself
r better principles that could be
denounced with words and algorithms
i learned that while most
people envision the future as a
slightly modified version of the present
it differs greatly from ordinary
the reason for this is that we are
being influenced  of the near past and that
we are unaware of the distant past of which it
happens that we have not experienced the
effects of our lifetime but these
events will repeat themselves
so I understood that what had
escaped me when I had mistakenly
predicted a  great depression was
hidden in the plot of the story
and that I could use what I
had recently learned from this plot
to make better decisions in
the future when I reflected on the challenges
that present is for me.
I saw that these were
inseparable twins I understood that a
fuller life required
increased risk taking and that knowing how to balance
risks and  rewards is
essential to an optimal life
imagine having the choice between a
safe and boring life by staying where you
are and a wonderful life by
risking the perilous journey
through a jungle full of dangers that is
basically our choice at  all
for me the question did not arise
which does not mean that the course
was easy I had above all to
overcome the two great obstacles which
await us all in the sixth
episode I will present precious
techniques to achieve this
I cannot  tell you that she sees
you have to borrow because I don't know
what is more important for you to
achieve our main objectives or
to save you from the suffering to
endure for that this is the courage
that I mentioned earlier
it is incumbent on each of you to  decide for
yourself my calamitous prediction of an
imminent catch had led me to one
of those crossroads of life we
ended up there are all if I had chosen p  for
the security of an ordinary life
my existence would have been very different
from what it is
but insofar as i could pay
the rent feed my family send
my children to school
my destiny was to cross the jungle
in search of  of the best possible life
the monumental mistake I had
made gave me a salutary fear of being
wrong
in other words it made me
deeply humble what I
needed
at the same time it did not  not prevented from
continuing to try to achieve my goals
to succeed I had to see
further than I could alone but the
two main obstacles that stand in the
way of each of us marc was my
ego and my blind spots
these obstacles result from the functioning
of our brain
let's start by exploring that of lego
the expression obstacles of lego
refers to those regions of our brain
that prevent us from recognizing our
weakness objectively and
thus learning to manage our fears  and our
deepest needs are buried
in the regions of the brain that control
our emotions and are not accessible
to your high level waking consciousness
and because our need to be
right can outweigh our need to
know the truth we are  inclined
to take our opinions for facts
without testing them
we especially dislike
contemplating our mistakes and weaknesses
we are instinctively inclined to
consider any
attempt to explore them as aggression we get away with it
when logic would
have us  take into account the feedback
of others our decisions suffer from it we
waste an opportunity to learn and we
remain below our potential
the second obstacle is that represented
by our blind spots
each of us has them it is about our
tendency to believe  that we can see
everything that surrounds us
in reality no one alone can
apprehend reality as a whole
it goes without saying that what  e we do
not see is incomprehensible to us like the
register of our voice our perception
of colors and our hearing our
vision and our apprehension of
reality of the aspects of our individual characteristics
so if some see
the whole
picture better others excel in  detail
some think in a straight
line others laterally some are
creative and unreliable others reliable
and uncreative and that's because our
brains differ we see the world
around us in our own
way acting naturally we don't
disregard our weaknesses and we
fail we can either continue
or change aristotle defines
tragedy as an appalling
result of a
person's fatal flaw had it been remedied
the result would have been wonderful
in my opinion these two obstacles are  the
main hindrances to making
good decisions
my fear of being wrong has brought me
openness  of radical spirit that I
needed, which changed everything for me,
taking risks and occasionally
running to ruin did not suit me
any more than not taking risks and
condemned me to
mediocrity I needed a  approach to generating
exceptional positive results without the
risk of monumental failure when I
discovered them
it was for me the holy grail it
simply required that I prefer
knowing the truth to the pleasure
of being right so I went in
search of people  the
smartest I have ever
met whose ideas differed from
mine their conclusions did
not interest me I just wanted to see the reality from
their point of view is to make them
see mine so that together we can
to scrutinize the real and discover the real
in other words I expected from them above
all an intelligent disagreement to pass
from a vision of the real through my
only glasses to its contemplation
through that of its bris  ltant
personalities was for me like
abandoning black and white for
color
the world becoming brighter I then understood
that the right way to cross the
jungle of life was to walk
with intelligent people with a
different perspective on things
think  to the five-step process
I've talked about before we're all
different
we can't all excel in
all five phases but you're
not alone ask for help from those who
succeed where you fail who
see what
escapes you just give up the illusion
that you can't come back to the
right answers on your own and use your fear
of error to open yourself to the point of
view of others so
you can see risks
and opportunities that  otherwise you would
escape I have found that this
radical open-mindedness combined with a
habit of weighting the
credibility of the reflection of the other
favored optimal decision-making
this  your attitude has allowed me to overcome
ever greater challenges
before i constantly would have preferred to
do what felt best to me
now that i seek out
the sharpest independent minds i have
n't stopped
nothing is more exhilarating than  a
common mission with extraordinary partners
said calm in honest
is true is radically transparent
to each other
this approach has led me to create a
society based on a unique meritocracy of
ideas operating in an
unprecedented way that has produced success
an unparalleled meritocracy of ideas
makes it possible to get the best from everyone
everyone thinks independently then
we discuss our disagreements to
reach the best solution but not
all opinions are equal and
we had to learn to distinguish
good ideas from bad ones to  lead
to optimal decisions,
in other words we had to gauge
the credibility of the reflection of  everyone
but this is another story
that I will come back to in my
professional principles you are at this
moment surrounded by
extraordinary opportunity and mortal perils that
you ignore if you want to look
are the distortions due to your ego
and your blind spots
you could  managed them much more
effectively
if you acquire this ability and
with practice it is possible you will
transform your life for the better
in the eighth episode i will conclude
our common wanderings so that
you can begin your own
journey so far i explained  how
I learned to face reality
problems my mistakes and my
weaknesses and how I surrounded myself
with people who could do
things better than me I couldn't
find a better way to
reach excellent decisions this  state
of mind is not acquired spontaneously
but it allowed me to succeed and this
success gave me the possibility of  e
benefit from the reflection of
exceptional personality
I found that their journey was
similar to mine
all experience difficulties and all
have weak points that they compensate
by working with people who
see the risks and opportunities that
escape them
I have  learned that by nature
our main strengths are often linked
to our greatest weaknesses and that the
efforts made to achieve
ambitious goals are not without
painful setbacks
some are inseparable from others
these setbacks test our courage
it separates the enduring  others
some think about the causes of
their failure learn from it and
continue to move forward
while others decide that the game is not worth
the candle and throw in the towel
I understand that success is not  I didn't have to
make goals achieved,
no, I noticed that each time I
climbed a rung on the success ladder,
Grenet's dissatisfaction erupted.  st very quickly
the goals we set are
simple to not reach them forces us
to evolve and the real reward lies
in this shared struggle to evolve
personally I no longer wanted to
wade through the jungle
I wanted to face
ever greater challenges  elbow to elbow with
remarkable individuals and
walk part of the common path with them at the end
the success of the mission and the well-being
of my fellow adventurers
became more important to me than my
own success
I also started  to look
beyond my own horizons and to desire
the success of others when I am
gone
I have understood that if
I do not do so I fail true I am still
struggling with this problem we
all have each other  with different
things until we give up
bourillon or become part of an
evolutionary quest that is beyond us this
is how all the
machines work that endlessly recycle the
elements  disintegrating machines
return to the system to aggregate
into other machines which in turn evolve
it happens that we are
saddened by this because we are very attached
to our machines
but for a distant observer the
functioning of the evolving machine
conceals  a real one
and it is up to you to decide how
you will evolve forget the origin of these
principles it is up to you to
determine if they are useful to you and
to make them evolve according to your needs
like all decisions
in life at the end of the day  count the choice
is yours and I hope you
will have the courage to fight valiantly
thank you and goodbye
[Music]